[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle édition spéciale
sur tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 29
avril 44e jour 2 confinement
commençons avec le point quotidien sur
la situation sanitaire dans le
département depuis le début de la
pandémie le colis 19 a causé la mort de
415 personnes dans les hôpitaux aux
yvelinois d'après les derniers chiffres
de santé publique france du 28 avril
2020 858 personnes atteintes du virus
sont hospitalisées soit 32 patients en
plus par rapport à la veille
enfin pour être complet sur le bilan
sanitaire 1343 yvelinois ont pu
retourner à leur domicile suite à
l'amélioration de leur état de santé
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
présenté hier les orientations pour la
stratégie de déconfinement à l'assemblée
nationale si certaines entreprises ont
déjà repris leur activité d'autres
commencent à réfléchir à leur
organisation équipements sanitaires
réorganisation de l'espace de travail et
des transports des salariés on écoute
sonia porot secrétaire départemental de
la cgt et thomas godefroy scola
président de la cpam des yvelines
ce qu'on demande aux entreprises c'est
qu' il y ait le moins possible de
salariés qui se rendent sur site s'est
passée cette mesure-là lequel moins de
déplacements et de contacts ça reste la
mesure de prévention principal est ce
qu'on demande c'est que tous les
salariés aient suffisamment de masques
de bonne qualité tous les jours ou mis à
disposition gratuitement par par les
entreprises y compris pour ceux qui qui
doivent prendre les transports en commun
pour pour aller au travail
évidemment qu'il y ait des infections
régulière des des locaux
mais c'est très très très très compliqué
à et c'est vraiment adapté dans chaque
dans chaque entreprise
j'ai beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise qui
évidemment ce fossile devenir très
important de la sécurité de leurs
salariés et qui ont quelques difficultés
pour pouvoir répondre à toutes les
conditions de sécurité et d'hygiène
c'est assez difficile par exemple le
souvenir des masques pour ça qu'on
sommes ravis que la région ait pu nous
en donner pour donner un ordre d'idée
quand la région m'a appelé pour me dire
qu'il me donnait 30 mille masques on a
fait en aide à nos adhérents est à la
base de données ces 5000 entreprises
dans le département donc 5000 sur 90
l'entreprise si on compte les
auto-entrepreneurs en cinq heures on est
obligé de couper le système on avait
déjà plus de former le monde il ya
effectivement de gros besoins au gel de
gros besoins au camp de gros besoins en
plexiglas pour ceux qui ont un contact
avec la clientèle
il ya toutes les entreprises du bâtiment
qui ont aussi des difficultés à pouvoir
s'organiser et que demi toujours les
loyers du mois d'avril sont annulés pour
les entreprises installées dans la
pépinière promo paul à montigny le
bretonneux au départ reporté le conseil
d'administration de la structure a
finalement décidé mardi 28 avril
l'annulation du paiement des loyers un
coup autour de 80 mille euros pour promo
paul pour le mois de mai le prélèvement
se fera normalement si des sociétés sont
en difficulté de trésorerie elles
peuvent contacter la direction pour
tenter de trouver une solution
on vous en parlait dans l'édition de
lundi l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien de trappes endeuillée par la
disparition du docteur jacques fribourg
un décès des suites du coc vie de 19 ans
ce médecin urgentiste de 68 ans avait
pris sa retraite en septembre 2019
il était revenu au centre hospitalier en
pleine crise du coronavirus pour
s'engager dans la lutte auprès de ses
confrères et nous sommes avec un de ses
confrères le docteur romain mario zoulou
wallonie bonjour bonjour
donc vous êtes médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien déjà
comment vous allez dans ce contexte de
crise sanitaire
c'est compliqué c'est plein de plein de
sentiments on tient le coup mais c'est
quand même compliqué puis ça l'est
encore plus depuis la semaine dernière
le shaq jacques ccc c'est un symbole
pour nous aider son hôpital dans son
établissement depuis un mois et s'est
battu comme un diable pour survivre il
décède chez nous c'est un sentiment
c'est beaucoup de tristesse c'est
énormément de tristesse
cc c'est particulier de voir partir
quelqu'un pour lequel on avait quand
même beaucoup de respect beaucoup
d'admiration beaucoup d'amitié d'amour
de le voir partir dans ces conditions
huit mois après son après sa retraite
j'ai pas vraiment de mots pour ça c'est
compliqué après nous si vous voulez
servir mois et demi qu'on se bat pour le
contre le connard en corner
ce métier donc je sais pas je faisais
moi j'ai l'impression un peu d'être
d'être dedans de la tête j'étais dans
d'idron est bon on verra plus tard tu
crois que je réfléchis pas trop en
termes de personnellement à titre
personnel je jouais là je suis plutôt
inquiet sur la situation actuelle
le confinement déconfinement la
percussion mon cas personnel je pense
pas trop en soit j'ai vite
la tristesse par rapport à la
disparition du docteur jacques rigaud
c'est quelqu'un que vous côtoyez depuis
longtemps ça fait 12 ans je suis arrivé
en 2008
jacky était déjà très impliqué puisqu'il
fait partie des trois fondateurs du
service avec les docteurs joël
renouveler le docteur françois thivet
les deux premiers enfants
françois et on jouait son parti restait
donc jacques qui te très investi et puis
j'ai des coordinateurs du service
pendant sept ans donc j'étais un peu
comme personnes qui reprennent donc on
est et on était très lié justement sur
les sur deux projets de projets de
services
il a beaucoup appuyé aussi pour la
rénovation de notre service initialement
voix après le projet il n'a pas eu la
passion vie puisqu'il était
effectivement un peu en retrait mais il
a quand même beaucoup fait justement
pour que ce seul ce projet puisse en
tout cas être initié par le le groupe
générale de santé
et voilà et puis jacques ont travaillé
ensemble tous les jours il ya chaque
fois qu'on est très régulièrement sein
du service donc oui c'est une car j'ai
côtoyé pendant 12 ans qui faisait partie
de notre fan notre famille il faisait
partie de la famille des semences vous
l'avez dit le docteur jacques fribourg
avait pris sa retraite en septembre 2010
n'est fait il revient dans cette crise
quel regard vous portez sur ce geste sur
ce geste de mobilisation c'est un geste
admirable et moi qui me paraît en même
temps comme jeudi et à meaux naturel par
les guerres virologique ainsi on parle
de tout cas pris la place d'un soldat
canton en temps de guerre donc jacques
comme beaucoup d'autres ont pris le
parti de se réinvestir comme lieu
pouvait jacques était très attaché à sa
mission au samu nous en parlait
énormément la vidéo de la régulation
téléphonique principalement des produits
c'était une évidence de continuer cette
mission par le biais justement du samu
et moi je suis je suis très admiratif de
ce qu'il a fait et en étant très
attristé parce que parce que parce que
du coup il s'est investi dans une
mission qu'il a peut être remporté je
sais pas peut-être peut-être pas je sais
pas en tout cas
c'est dur c'est dur de le voir finir
comme ça en tout cas quels souvenirs
vous garderez de lui mettre une anecdote
quelque chose des moments que vous avez
vécu et jacques c'était un très très bon
vivant dont il aimait beaucoup la
musique mais beaucoup des copains les
métiers où beaucoup la bonne bouffe le
bon petit coup à boire de temps en temps
mais évidemment trop de travail
vous imaginez bien mais voilà c'était
quand il était de garde la première
question qui posait quand il arrivait
c'était de savoir ce qu'on avait
commandé à manger il aimait bien qu'on
lui tapote sur le ventre il aimait bien
parler de tweets ou n'importe quoi il
avait une voix particulière donc qu'ils
aient comprendraient pas toujours disait
parce qu'il paraît un peu dans sa barbe
et tout ça ça faisait rire tout le monde
mais ça faisait partie du personnage et
il était très attachant il avait comme
aussi son caractère donc c'était
quelqu'un avec qui on pouvait excusez
moi du terme s'engueuler mais il n'y
avait pas de ressentiment en tout cas il
n'y avait pas de risque de le voir être
rancunier donc
donc voilà donc c'était la vie un
jacques c'était un c'était c'était
c'était un homme de vie en fait voilà
donc tout ce qu'on peut connaître dans
une vie on ne vivait avec lui au
quotidien
et voilà c'est difficile en deux par des
danses et plein de sentiments que j'ai
l'impression pas pouvoir tout décrire un
mais je suis évidemment très attristé
par à 70 un dernier mot comment vous
voyez si on parle de la crise sanitaire
comment vous voyez là les prochains
jours l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire pour finir sur feu sur la
description de cette espèce très
rapidement beaucoup d'inquiétude
beaucoup d'inquiétude parce que parce
que justement donc les gens vont
ressortir que pour l'instant le niveau
de circulation du virus encore dit de
france et quand même je pense encore
relativement élevé
bien évidemment il est compliqué 1 2 que
tenir encore une population sous
confinement et on sent bien content
d'arrêter clairement sortant mais moi je
suis très inquiet et je pense que mon
corps risque effectivement de voir
développer deuxième bague à sa grande
inquiétude de tous les professionnels de
tentes de santé de voir cette deuxième
vague et là nous on a énormément de
difficultés si vous voulez parce que les
patients non
vide ressort donc le nous il faut qu'on
interne on s'organise avec encore deux
flux mais influent pour l'instant que
vides qui qui est très faible mais qui
mobilise encore beaucoup de personnel et
l'autre côté un flux non qu'ovide qui
commence aussi à embouteiller pas mal de
services
et puis on sait pas comment réagir on
sait pas comment s'adapter c'est très
difficile de s'adapter
c'est une adaptation au quotidien donc
pour l'instant en fait nous c'est
surtout de l'inquiétude par rapport à
une deuxième vague savoir comment on va
être amené à la gérer donc on verra à
partir de mi juin que ça ce que ça ce
que ça va occasionner merci docteur
romain mahieu zoulou elle ni pour se
battre aux freinages et pour fait que le
cerveau merci à vous de nous avons dit
c'est le temps pouvoir justement nous
exprimer dans leur antre match ajax
merci beaucoup merci à vous et bon
courage pour la poursuite de merci de
vos activités dans cette crise sanitaire
merci au revoir
les vétérinaires sont aussi impactés par
cette crise les rendez-vous et
chirurgies non urgentes ont été annulés
depuis le début du confinement des
modifications qui concerne nos amis à
quatre pattes
les vétérinaires ont dû modifier en
profondeur leur manière de travailler
entre soins et sécurité le quotidien de
ces soignants est possible bouleversé le
récit de mathilde demi coûts qui doit
sortir du cabinet après une lourde
opération
aujourd'hui il fait quelques examens de
contrôle les animaux et les gens très
pâle avec l'épidémie de covile 19
l'équipe de ce cabinet vétérinaire a dû
revoir son organisation
les actes non indispensables et
certaines chirurgies ont été reportés
des activités qui représente en temps
normal 25 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
on s'est mis à prendre des rendez vous
toutes les demi heures y compris pour
les prise d'aliments les gens devaient
appeler pour venir chercher leurs
aliments on a mis n'est pas nos salles
d'attentes on a de manière à ce qu'ils
aient jamais plus d'une seule personne
en salles d'attentes avec une seule
personne qui apporte l'animal on évite
de trop touchée où que ce soit même les
caisses de transport des chats on évite
que que ça traîne un peu partout on est
on leur donne une place est sur la table
de consultation et ça reste sur la table
de deux consultations des infections
après chaque consultation le sol du
cabinet nettoyer trois fois par jour et
les effectifs ont été réduits mais comme
beaucoup de soignants c'est le matériel
de protection qui pose problème
on s'occupe pas trop de nous dire
comment on s'est débrouillé un peu par
nous-mêmes pour
pour tout ce qui va et hygiène je sais
que la mairie ait les raisons elle a
donné des masques aux causes autres
commerçants ouverts il paraît que la
région ile-de-france va nous faire
parvenir via les mairies des masques
mais on les attend encore avec le
déconfinement les équipes ans repasser à
des horaires d'ouverture classique
philippe aigrain estime que son activité
sera touchée pendant encore quatre à
cinq mois
depuis le 16 mars une dizaine d'animaux
sont soignés chaque jour au lieu de 30
pour simba le chat du cabinet par contre
rien n'a changé depuis le 14 mars avant
même le début du confinement le poney
club du cpa montigny a fermé ses portes
suite à un arrêté municipal plus
d'activités plus d'adhérents pour sortir
les équidés des boks c'est la directrice
du site qui s'occupe à présent seuls des
poney pour éviter les pertes financières
un reportage de mathilde me
comme depuis le début du confinement
christine haxaire est l'unique salarié à
venir s'occuper du poney club de l'ucp à
montigny le bretonneux
aidé par sa famille qui logent sur place
elle dédie sa journée aux équidés non
s'embête pas du tout pendant le
confinement on a plutôt des journées
encore plus chargé qu'avant puisque les
et qui démontre tous les jours tous les
matins à 8h30 il faut être là pour les
nourrir les mettre en liberté remettent
de la paille prob vider la paille salle
on continue l'entretien au travail des
équidés qui sont présents sur site donc
on les montons et longe on a récupéré
donc de l'herbe dans la ferme du mas
n'est donc on a pu créer des petits
paddock où on arrive à mettre tous les
poneys à tour de rôle à partir de 11h
jusqu'à 16h donc ça leur fait voilà des
belles journées pour permettre aux
équidés de se dégourdir la ferme du mané
qui est fermée au public a mis à
disposition les jardins inoccupé depuis
le 14 mars
le poney club n'a plus aucune activité
et les pertes financières commencent à
se faire ressentir
on n'est pas encore concerné par toutes
ces aides là il faut savoir qu'on est
une association
donc on fait pas toujours partie des
bonnes cases pour avoir toutes les aides
je pense que les choses vont s'affiner
au fur et à mesure des décrets qui passe
pour les aides gouvernementales et on
espère bien sûr pouvoir toucher des
aides pour nous permettre de continuer à
perdurer l'activité
cette directrice espère néanmoins une
réouverture rapide du site pour
permettre de reprendre les activités et
le retour des adhérents tout en
respectant les gestes barrières sur les
sports ils sont que ce soit plutôt mime
et qu'on ait des informations de toute
façon on suivra les décisions
gouvernementales et les décisions
municipales puisque effectivement le
maire a aussi son droit de regard sur
l'activité et on appliquera bien sûr
tout ce qui sera demandé par le
gouvernement on espère bien sûr pouvoir
reprendre au plus vite avec toutes les
précautions sanitaires nécessaires
en attendant la reprise d'activité pour
lui cpa montini les poneys continueront
une forme des coûts pâturages dans la
ferme du mas né au mois de juin 600
bénévoles auraient dû être rassemblés au
château de rambouillet pour une
reconstitution historique
mais comme de nombreux rendez vous
culturel secret défense c'est le nom de
l'événement et reporter les équipes
créatrices ont pris la décision en cette
période de coronavirus et la
reconstitution aura finalement lieu du 4
au 27 juin 2021 ce projet vise à faire
revivre au public un moment historique
celui de la rencontre entre le président
charles de gaulle et son homologue
américain dwight eisenhower pour suivre
l'évolution du projet le site s'affiche
en bas de l'écran et en attendant la
réouverture des salles de cinéma courant
juin d'après les annonces du premier
ministre
le septième art se découvre à la maison
comme chaque mercredi nous vous
proposons des idées de films à voir ou à
revoir avec notre séquence dans vos
canapés et c'est quentin dupuis
réalisateur yvelinois qui nous donnent
des conseils
ombre au canapé cette semaine j'ai
choisi storz épisode iv un nouvel espoir
parce que en ces temps on est tous
confinés je pense que c'est une bonne
chose de repartir dans une direction
lointaine très lointaine et pouvoir
veiller à travers les étoiles et de
prendre le temps de rêver de s'évader un
petit peu je suis un énorme fan donc
forcément le choix a été facile puis
j'ai moi même profité du confinement
pour tous les regards des mois la ccsa
mais toujours de bonne humeur c'est star
wars c'est quelque chose qui fait appel
à l'imaginaire des grands des petits
sets et enfin c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'on peut revoir et revisitée à
chaque fois c'est le bien contre le mal
c'est quelque chose je pense que pendant
cette période qui est compliquée pour
tout le monde qui est difficile qui peut
redonner un petit peu des repères dû se
dire voilà il ya des belles choses que
ça redonne le sourire et que ça vous
donne envie aux gens de se dire bah il
l'avenir peut être meilleur l'avenir
sera meilleur et que on peut on peut
toujours rêver s'évader même quand les
choses sont difficiles dans la vie de
tous les jours suite aux menaces à 7 à
croire qu'il est protégé par la fois
c'est premier qui est sorti moi je pense
que c'est par suis là qu'il faut
commencer
voilà qui est sorti en 1977 et qui a
posé les bases aujourd'hui pour toute la
saga star wars et tout ce que star wars
est devenu aujourd'hui en terme de deux
phénomènes culturels et
cinématographique donc c'est vrai que
pour moi ça reste celui qui dans mon
coeur une passe vraiment particulière
parce que c'est le premier que j'ai vu
quand j'étais petit et qui pose vraiment
toutes les bases de l'histoire et de ce
cas star wars et de ce que ça représente
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis et mission a retrouvé
en replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 restez à
votre domicile et prenez soin de vous et
on se quitte sur ces images des hyènes
du zoo de thoiry deux animateurs du parc
zoologique partagent les moments de vie
des animaux sur les réseaux sociaux
excellente soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
à